[Musique]
eh bien nous sommes prêts
eh bien c'est la première fois que j'interviewe
quelqu'un d'autre je suis très excité certaines de
ces questions que j'ai peut-être écrites
avant de voir le film donc les films
s'appellent Eddie l'Aigle et maintenant tu joues
Eddie non  non non non tu l'as bien vu
mec oh non je l'ai fait ouais ouais je veux dire c'est
ouais qui vient bien et beaucoup d'acteurs aiment
faire leurs propres cascades oui fais-tu
tout ton propre jeu s'il y a des
scènes de sexe je les fais oui c'est là que se trouve le
métier  ouais c'est la clé d'un bon
mariage avez-vous reçu des notes
du studio - alors la bouche fermée d'Eddie fait
tirer des lasers de ses yeux vous savez que je
ne l'ai pas fait mais j'ai pensé que ce serait une bonne
idée comme histoire ça fait totalement  sens
que tu fais toujours partie d'un ensemble à cent pour cent ne
vieillis-tu jamais depuis 2009 tu sais
magnifique tu es deux fois vainqueur de Tony
tu es un acteur nominé aux Oscars hmm maintenant
combien de l'immense succès de Hugh Jackman
est le talent brut hmm et combien
est juste une structure osseuse avantageuse
merci d'être venu de  l'homme le plus sexy du monde
2012 10 ouais nous sommes au-dessus de l'
ancien modèle Je vais ouvrir ceci à
quelques questions de fans ici que j'ai eues la
première vient de Brian Glenn vieux de
Vancouver Colombie-Britannique meilleur huit
j'aime l'Amérique latine c'est incroyable Brian
demande Hugh j'ai entendu dire que sur x-men
Wolverine mmm-hmm vous aviez des
ascenseurs spécialement conçus pour mettre vos chaussures afin que
vous sembliez plus grand qu'un de vos
co-stars est-ce vrai ou juste un
fait idiot c'est c'est vrai j'ai fait la
question suivante mais mais  c'était une histoire pour
laquelle tout dans ce film concernait l'
histoire et le personnage
désolé de l'améliorer vous savez ouais ouais ma
prochaine question ici vient d'un Blake
Lively de New York New York
il écrit Hugh j'ai essayé de t'appeler sur
le téléphone du brûleur et  tu n'as pas répondu
est-ce qu'on se retrouve toujours à l'
hôtel Gansevoort cet après-midi je ne sais pas
combien de temps parce que Ryan a une
manucure de 3h00 à 4h00 ouais
j'ai une manucure de 3:  00 à 4:00
tu vas ouais c'est super bizarre
maintenant ce film parle de voler haut ouais
dis-moi la dernière fois que tu as expérimenté
avec des drogues laquelle était et tu en as en
ce moment non non non j'adorerais
juste un peu de travail de scène et
j'aimerais juste ramasser  quelques conseils si
tu es si tu vas bien sûr que ce que j'aimerais que
tu fasses, c'est que je prenne ce couteau et que
je le tienne d'accord d'accord ouais d'accord et
je vais dire quelque chose d'accord tiens bon
ça va oh mon dieu il est  j'ai un couteau
maintenant tu dis ouais ouais ce n'est pas un couteau
maintenant ça suffit oh merci
beaucoup Hugh Jackman mon plaisir
honnêtement c'était mon interview préférée
que j'ai jamais donnée Merci Ryan Reynolds
est le seul que tu aies jamais donné  c'est
et ce sera le dernier